we're told that laney runs a string of
lights from the ground straight up to a
door frame that is 2.5 meters tall
then they run the rest of the string in
a straight line to a point on the ground
that is six meters from the base of the
door frame
there are 10
lights per meter of the string how many
total lights are on the string so pause
this video and see if you can work this
out
all right now let's work through this
together and i think this one warrants
some type of a diagram so let me draw
this door frame
that looks like this
and this door frame is 2.5 meters tall
so that's its height right over there
and what they're going to do
what laney's doing is
she is stringing up these lights so
that's this yellow right over here so it
goes up to the top of that door frame
and then
they run the rest of the light in a
straight line to a point on the ground
that is six meters from the base of the
door frame so let me show a point that
is six meters from the base of the door
frame so it would look something
like
maybe like that
so this distance right over here is six
meters so they run the rest of the light
from the top of the door frame to that
point that's six meters away so the
yellow right over here that is the light
and so we need to figure out how many
total lights are on the string so the
way i would tackle it is first off first
of all i want to figure out how
how long is the total string and to
figure that out i just need to figure
out okay it's going to be 2.5 plus
whatever the hypotenuse is of this right
triangle i think it's safe to assume
that this is a standard house where door
frames are at a right angle to the floor
and so we have to figure out the length
of this hypotenuse and if we know that
plus this 2.5 meters then we know how
long the entire string of lights are and
then we just have to really multiply it
by 10 because there's 10 lights per
meter of the string so let's do that so
how do we figure out the hypotenuse here
well of course we would use pythagorean
theorem so let's call this
let's call this h for hypotenuse we know
that the hypotenuse squared is equal to
2.5
squared
plus 6
squared so this is going to be equal to
6.2
plus
36
which is equal to 42.25
or we could say that the hypotenuse is
going to be equal to the square root of
42
42.25
and i could get my calculator out at
this point but i'll actually just keep
using this expression to figure out the
total number of lights
so what's the total length of the string
we have to be careful here a lot of
folks would say oh i figured out the
hypotenuse let me just multiply that by
10. in fact my brain almost did that
just now but we got to realize that the
entire string is the hypotenuse plus
this 2.5 so the whole string length let
me write this way string
length
is equal to
2.5
plus
the square root of
42.25 and then we would just multiply
that times 10 to get the total number of
lights so now let's actually get the
calculator out
so we have 42.25
and then we were to take the square root
of that
gets us to 6.5 and then we add the other
2.5 plus
2.5
equals that that's the total length of
string so the total length of string is
9 meters and there are 10 lights per
meter
so the number of lights
number
of lights
is equal to
9 total meters of string times
10
lights
per meter which would give us
90
lights
now some of you might debate if you
think really deeply about it is if you
have a light right at the beginning if
these were kind of set up like fence
posts that maybe you could argue that
there's one extra light in there but for
the sake of this i kind of view this as
on average there are 10 lights per meter
and so if it's a 9 meter string
9 times 10 is 90 lights